la vieille ville
c'était une grande inspiration pour mes
livres loin de la lumière des parfums et
de la vie qui continue à damas comme
pour se remémorer sans cesse sa ville
adorée
nadine kadan dessine il raconte des
histoires pour enfants
j'ai commencé quand j'avais peut-être
huit ans ou 9 ans à l'école j'ai jamais
arrêté jamais arrêté né à paris il ya 35
ans elle a vécu toute sa vie dans la
capitale syrienne
jusqu'en 2012 après une première année
de conflit qui a semé la mort et la
destruction sur son chemin et l'a décidé
à contre-coeur de quitter son pays pour
vivre à londres en étaient les premières
victimes les enfants les familles
s'étant victime d'une guerre cruelle
elle depuis qu'elle dessine
elle a publié une quinzaine de livres
pour enfants et pendant cette guerre qui
s'éternisait sa palette de couleurs est
devenu beaucoup plus sombre et l'a écrit
tomorrow demain l'histoire de yaz anne
petit garçon syrien dont la vie change
parce qu'il ne peut plus aller au parc
comme avant il ya une tristesse
bien sûr parce que c'est une histoire
qui parle de la guerre mais il n'ya
toujours d'espoir toujours toujours
toujours d'espoir et pour moi c'est ce
que je voulais dire dans cette histoire
que je sais c'est temporaire
la gare est temporaire après la
publication du livre et l'a rencontré et
lui son livre à des enfants réfugiés
dans les camps du liban de la turquie et
de la jordanie
la première fois pour moi c'était une
surprise parce que c'était un thérapie
parce que les enfants vous voulez me
dire son expérience de la guerre elle
qui s'est initié à la lecture et à
l'illustration grâce aux auteurs
occidentaux déplore aujourd'hui le peu
de représentations de sa culture dans
les livres pour enfants
il n'y a pas beaucoup de diversité
culturelle
alors c'est pour ça c'est mon but
j'aimerai toujours à dessiner écrire des
histoires qui représente qui symbolise
et 7
ancien un ratage marwijk c'est ainsi que
nadine kadan parcours les tribunes pour
mieux faire connaître sa culture portée
par l'espoir d'un monde meilleur
la syrienne a écrit aussi des livres
plus joyeux qui sont des lettres d'amour
à sa ville comme dans l'histoire
d'haroun un chat en mission pour
éradiquer la source de ses éternuements
le jasmin des chats et pour moi c'était
la scène de damas qui écrit l'histoire
c'est pour rigoler c'est pour pour la
mémoire de ma vie aujourd'hui ely ces
histoires à ma'an son fils de deux ans
et le fait aussi bien en anglais qu'en
arabe pour préserver son identité
il ya des enfants qui parlent pas là
après c'est pour moi c'est très
difficile parce que la langue c'est
l'identité et la langue est très
important même si importante pour
apprendre un autre langue
bran est devenu aussi une inspiration
majeure pour son travail
chaque jour il ya quelque chose de
nouveau c'est pour ça j'ai moi je me
sens que j'ai que j'écris mieux j'ai 2
signant avec lui très bientôt élire à
rendre visite à ses parents qui ont
décidé de rester en syrie malgré le
conflit parce que éternel optimiste le
meilleur est à venir
la gare est temporaire c'est pas non et
c'est pas quelque chose qui nous
représente
hélas pu retrouver ses parfums mais
cette lumière qui lui manque tant
comme un raid se gardent en tête ou est
ce juste fibre litres seulement si
frédéric arnould radio canada montréal